sony menus are just terrible some things
are okay but most things have no logic
so today i'm gonna show you my custom
button mapping so you don't have to go
into the menus like ever or almost never
let's start with three most important
buttons iso shutter speed and aperture i
assign the iso to the wheel the shutter
speed to the rear dial and the aperture
to the front dial
these are the functions i cannot live
without
next on the list is the custom one and
custom two buttons i have them assigned
as creative style which has all the
classic styles like vivid standard
neutral and so on and custom 2 is
assigned to a picture profile where i
have my custom film simulations these
are film profiles i've been working on
for the past year more info about that
in an upcoming video
okay so let's get to the dial on the
dial knob i have two memory calls which
basically remembers every setting frame
rate resolution that you have set on the
camera on the moment of saving
so
you can easily switch let's say between
4k 25p to full hd 50p or full hd 100b
and that is so powerful just imagine
being at a wedding and you just need uh
just realize you need 100 p right now
like boom swap the knob and you're there
no menus no time wasted on searching is
just awesome but here it becomes even
more interesting
memory recall doesn't only save your
speed settings and frame rate or
whatsoever it also saves picture
profiles which means that on this camera
you can actually save up to 30 original
picture profiles and now you're like wow
but why do i need 30 picture profiles on
this camera
and most people are fine with only 5 or
10 picture profiles and that's okay but
maybe you're just like me and you
already have like 10 profiles that you
like and do not want to modify
so you just maybe need one or two extra
slots to experiment without losing the
original settings of one particular
profile so you can do this while in one
of the memory recon modes and the cool
thing is at the end of the day if you
don't want to keep the changes brought
to the profile you just have to switch
the dial and it resets completely to the
original
that's how i did the 10 filming profiles
okay so back to the subject button
mapping
the next button is set to live view
display and as you can see this enables
or disables the real-time effects of the
settings
the button next to it is set to magnify
for fast focus checking which is also
super helpful if you're shooting in the
studio and you want to micro adjust the
focus but this works only in manual
focus so be aware of that the focus
joystick controls the focus point but if
you push in the middle just like
clicking it opens up the kelvin menu
this is probably my favorite and most
used shortcut because it's just so easy
to change color without going into the
menu last but not least if you push the
wheel upwards it will change the
on-screen display of settings if you
push the wheel to the left it will open
the drive mode menu which is super
helpful to change from single to high or
maybe bracketing now if i push the right
button on the wheel it opens up the
metering mode menu which is good for
different exposure metering push it
downwards and it will give you silent
shooting options if you press the middle
point of the wheel it will bring up the
aspect ratio which is 16x9 or 4x3 the
trash bin enables or disables touch
functionality custom button 3 is
assigned to super 35 mode if you need
extra reach
and finally the function button opens up
the display menu where you can change
stuff like audio zebra and so
on i recorded my custom button menu
interface so it's easier for you to make
the same mapping and i hope this video
saved you some time
if you did please hit the like button
and subscribe if you want to be notified
of any new videos
that's pretty much it see in the next
one
[Music]
[Music]
you